.
THE EFFECTS ARE HITTING REAL
PEOPLE IN REAL TIME.
RANDI KAYE VISITED AN ABORTION
CLINIC IN ALABAMA, ONE OF THREE
IN THE STATE.
>> ALABAMA WOMEN'S CENTER.
>> Reporter: IT'S ONLY 8:00 A.M.
AND THE PHONES AT THE ALABAMA
WOMEN'S CENTER IN HUNTSVILLE ARE
RINGING OFF THE HOOK.
JUST DAYS AFTER ABORTION
SUDDENLY BECAME ILLEGAL IN THIS
STATE, THIS IS NOW THE STANDARD
RESPONSE FROM STAFF.
>> THIS IS THE OVERTURN OF ROE
VERSUS WADE.
WE RECOMMEND YOU CONSIDER
LOOKING INTO OTHER STATES.
>> Reporter: THIS 18-YEAR-OLD
SHOWED UP AT THE CLINIC TODAY
STILL HOPING TO GET AN ABORTION
BUT WAS TOLD THEY COULDN'T SPEAK
WITH HER.
SHE SAYS SHE'S TWO MONTHS
PREGNANT.
>> DID YOU KNOW ROE V. WADE HAD
BEEN OVERTURNED.
>> I DID.
BUT I DIDN'T KNOW IT ALREADY WAS
CAUSING PLACES TO STOP DOING
THEM.
>> Reporter: SO YOU THOUGHT YOU
COULD COME HERE AND GET AN
ABORTION TODAY.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: WHAT DID YOU THINK
WHEN YOU REALIZED?
>> I STARTED CRYING.
I JUST DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR.
NO MATTER THE SITUATION, I FEEL
LIKE YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
AN ABORTION.
>> Reporter: DR. ROBINSON RUNS
THE CLINIC IN ALABAMA, ONE OF
THREE, BEFORE ROE WAS
OVERTURNED.
>> I FELT POWERLESS AS A
PHYSICIAN.
YOU KNOW?
I KNOW HOW TO CARE FOR THESE
PATIENTS.
IT'S LIKE YOU HAVE THE TOOLS TO
HELP SOMEBODY AND YOU CHOOSE NOT
TO HELP THEM.
AND THAT WAS HARD FOR ME.
>> Reporter: ABORTION IS NOW
ILLEGAL IN ALABAMA EXCEPT IN
CASES WHERE THE HEALTH OF THE
MOTHER IS SUBSTANTIALLY AT RISK
OR THE FETUS ISN'T EXPECTED TO
SURVIVE.
THERE ARE NO EXCEPTIONS FOR RAPE
OR INCEST.
IF PROVIDERS BREAK THE LAW, THEY
COULD GO TO PRISON.
>> I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT MY
ATTORNEYS HAVE TOLD ME IS SAFE
FOR ME TO SAY.
AND SO I FEEL LIKE SOMEBODY'S
CALLING ME FOR HELP AND I'M
GIVING THEM A VAGUE ANSWER AND
IT FEELS VERY HYPOCRITICAL TO
ME.
>> YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT AIDING
AND ABETTING.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Reporter: THIS 18-YEAR-OLD,
WHO ASKED NOT TO BE IDENTIFIED,
CAME TO THIS CLINIC FOR AN
ABORTION JUST DAYS FOR ROE WAS
OVERTURNED.
>> I'M PROUD OF THE DECISION I
MADE.
>> Reporter: SHE WAS 11 WEEKS
PREGNANT WHEN SHE HAD HER
ABORTION AND IS GRATEFUL SHE HAD
A CHOICE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
THOSE WOMEN WHO HAVE BEEN TURNED
AWAY OR HAD APPOINTMENTS
CANCELLED AND WILL NO LONGER BE
ABLE TO GET AN ABORTION FOR
THOSE GIRLS.
>> I FEEL SO BAD FOR THOSE
GIRLS.
THIS WAS A HARD DECISION FOR ME.
I COULDN'T IMAGINE BEING LOOKED
IN MY FACE AND TOLD NO.
>> Reporter: NOW THE OTHER 18
DWRO WE MET WAS TOLD NO, SHE'S
EVEN MORE SCARED AS SHE TRIES TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO NEXT.
DO YOU FEEL SORT OF LOST RIGHT
NOW?
>> MM-HM.
>> Reporter: YEAH.
DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHERE
YOU'LL GO?
>> MM-MM.
>> Reporter: DOUFL LIKE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE FORCED TO HAVE THIS
BABY?
>> I MEAN, I KNOW I'M GONNA -- I
KNOW I'M GOING TO GET IT DONE.
BUT I'M GOING TO TRY BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT IT.
AND I DON'T WANT TO HAVE IT, SO
I'M GOING